they Banned Me from YouTube  then they Banned Me from Discord  then they banned me for Airbnb  they Banned Me from stripe  they've been I can't even remember it  was just emails coming in faster than  you could believe  oh no no the Matrix presses a button my  friend and every app on your phone stops  working Uber  you name it Uber stop you name it wait  you can't use Uber well I can use Uber  you just start a new account right but  yeah oh sorry Uber okay but uh with your  main account on Uber was taken they take  everything from you and everything  everyone made an effort all at once  ones every single one of them just goes  no delete delete delete delete and I  come at you and they come back with  everything that's right payment process  uk-based Banks as well High Street Banks  but I can name Santander HSBC Barclays  Etc all at the same time oh no sorry the  change we've decided because blah blah  some [ __ ] some let her close your  accounts